hi Dennis it's not the same thing but
that doesn't it Larry hey buddy I'm good
yeah
what's happening what's we're just
talking about megyn kelly coming out and
saying that she complained about Bill
O'Reilly but it wasn't the complaint
that we were hoping for like it wasn't
what does she say somebody something he
said on TV as opposed to something he
did behind the scenes yes she made like
the news headline made it seem like
megyn kelly says she complained about
Bill O'Reilly because bill said nobody
ever complained about me to HR and I'm
going and I think everybody's going oh
my god did Bill O'Reilly sexually harass
megyn kelly and then megyn kelly
complained about and there's a but then
you click the video and you listen to
megyn kelly and she said that she
watched Bill O'Reilly do an interview
right for one of the other morning shows
and she complained to Fox about what he
was saying on the interview and I'm
going whoa what are we even talking
about I complained about Bill O'Reilly
many times you did yeah and I complained
and I was sexually harassed by manure I
was on his show yeah he touched my leg
uh-huh and it was horrifying and it
scarred me but I was pushing a book so I
just kept going with the interview if
you guys want to sexually harass me
right now it's fine as long as we talk
about the bar yes in the book sexually
harassing yet I don't care it could be a
great headline great way for me to sell
some copies Jim Norton is sexually
harassed and molested Denis Leary today
they'd sign with me they look at you
that understands like we go as far as
sexual assault uh you okay yeah you want
to do the James Toback I just I guess
hump my leg while I grab your nipples
that's right you may forgot I forgot
yeah my nipples and look me in the eye
oh yeah yeah creepy you've been in
Hollywood for a long time as this stuff
is as as weird for you as it is for us
are you one of the guys they're like
yeah I kind of knew this was happening
no I didn't know Weinstein when I first
got famous which is like ninety-two
Weinstein Harvey Weinstein was just
becoming Harvey Weinstein so the company
was like
no it's just making their bones so to
speak but I can't remember what it was
but it was there was a there was
something he wanted when I first met him
it was something he wanted to for me to
do for his company some movie like it
was like a beam action movie or
something and I didn't know the guy and
he walked up and he you know within
seconds he presented himself as a bullet
you know the stomach was hanging out he
had a cigarette gallery he's gonna like
that I'm Harvey Weinstein You Know Who I
am and I want you to do that and I was
like I'm not doing that and they kept oh
you're gonna do it because my company
and I can I can make a break your career
and I was like go [ __ ] yourself you were
saying that 90 day yeah so but you know
I knew he was a bully so I said I'm not
[ __ ] doing it pal and as soon as I
said I'm not [ __ ] doing it like the
second time he was like I'm buying all
your drinks and from that moment on
every time I ran into the guy he was a
nicest guy in the world to me really but
he was an [ __ ] to a lot of [ __ ]
people did you wind up doing the movie
or no I did a movie for now I didn't do
the movie but I did a couple movies for
his company I never had a problem with
him ran into him here and there and I'll
sure whatever because he was a [ __ ]
bully and once you pushed him back
right it's like any bully he's like hey
now we're best friend right right I
didn't know I didn't know uh you know I
knew his reputation for a womanizer
whatever I didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't
have to deal with the guy yeah and
there's enough guys a [ __ ] different
girl it's like womanizing is one thing
if a guy cheats writes his business it's
like that I love when these things these
guys were by the way this Avalanche is
[ __ ] happening big-time now so
they're on yeah like Toback now it's all
it's just all gonna [ __ ] roll out
which I think as a result of Trump
winning the election so I think that
although Trump not to make a pun he had
the trump card on Hillary when we all
remember where we were on grabbed the
[ __ ] weekend sure on that Friday
so you know he Bill Clinton's sexual
history was [ __ ] solved that by the
time that Sunday night debate happened
so from Friday what everybody was saying
oh he's out he's done he's cooked he
just used the you know Bill Clinton's
sexual history against them right so
anyways I think from that moment on this
thing has turned into a snowball I think
now more and more guys are gonna get
busted on this [ __ ] I think it's great
guys I got power that we're [ __ ] with
people underneath him yeah Roger Ailes
to Bill O'Reilly with the one like once
when people are like oh my god Lee if
you can get Roger Ailes out of Fox yeah
and also uh-uh-uh-uh the O'Reilly 32
million dollar thing it's just like
crazy
what does she have I want to know I know
- I want the same thing does she is it
did he send a video of him like did he
walk off into his own hand I don't know
she have now Jim that sounds like the
voice of experience today I haven't
played in 4k making bird sounds Jim's
like no I've never made bird yeah I
didn't do the birds I did dog sounds
right I make pig noises Jesus Christ
yeah I don't what does she have I don't
know so I was 32 million dollars worth
of this is career-ending beyond repair I
got to pay the thirty two million and
then sign up for 25 yeah yeah I also
don't know like crazy Cox news Cox is it
what do you do when you have that much
on the line how are you making 32
million dollar risks like I don't know -
[ __ ] I don't know you know I paid thirty
two million dollars I have an eyewitness
I would I think a lot of people would
pay a lot of money to now to just to
find out what the thirty two million
dollars right yeah I mean [ __ ] a that
is I mean I there's been larger
settlements from or lawsuits we talked
about yesterday where the companies lose
in court right but I understand he had a
hundred million coming in but that's
before taxes after all that and he's
probably making fifty or fifty-five
million out of that money after agent
fees and taxes so to spend thirty-two
and know you're gonna clear 55 in four
years it's a lot that's I mean that's a
[ __ ] massive hit dad he [ __ ] up
something bad happen yeah yeah I'd like
to find out the clock in details it has
to be required he's still like doing his
streaming new channel here thing and
saying New York Times it's a it's a slam
and a smear I mean you know he's [ __ ]
up everywhere because he's doing his
podcast yeah I think to it no okay no
but he keeps he keeps going out and
doing interviews to promote the thing
and I feel like every time as long as
he's just tucked away doing his podcast
he's fine yes but every time he jumps
back in the spotlight it's more how is
what is the what are the figures on the
Dennis Miller Bill O'Reilly live show
that they do now they still selling out
I'm gonna guess really I don't know you
should find that out
that would be well because it's a
different thing to say I'm gonna I'm
gonna buy the new killing [ __ ]
whatever the book is that [ __ ] coming
out right we all know we want to see we
would love to read the book about the
thirty two million dollar settlement you
can still buy a Bill O'Reilly product
like online you know and Ben stops here
doormat whatever the [ __ ] it is right
and not embarrass yourself but if you
have to go to a [ __ ] hockey arena or
wherever the concert is with him and
Dennis Miller you have to show your face
so I'm very interested to see what their
numbers are that price still defend them
because again it's all been settlement
they don't care they probably knew it's
true and they just think we like bill
right you like his take and people
trying to bring him down
yeah the light hope it'll affect
anything to be honestly I don't know do
you hear the last that's why I'm asking
for the liveness
yeah I think they wouldn't go to the
shows anymore I can't imagine that you'd
go to a live Bill O'Reilly show [ __ ]
knows now you want to talk about it will
he say anything no way I mean that's
they just want you know it's gotta be a
lonely place to live in the O'Reilly
house he's mad at God so there's two
quotes I read from O'Reilly Baltimore
yesterday the first was that he was mad
at God for everything that's happened to
him he said yeah I am kind of mad at God
it's okay God didn't got his Walt the
second one was why did God give me this
[ __ ] that stop music why did God invent
porn yeah I keep setting it to women
what's wrong with me and falafels why
did he [ __ ] invent this yacht
invented the lugar [ __ ] flamin God
and then then you know on the hardcore
Catholic right he's like yeah yes merit
God yeah cuz I guess he can just say is
like however many things he's got to do
you know for forgiveness yeah right the
like I forget I was a Catholic right
know the you do like 10 Hail Marys and
our fathers act the contrition right but
then it's not but then the rest of it I
can't believe I pulled act of contrition
[ __ ] I haven't thought of that in 25
years no I just - it's weird that I said
that anyways then he also goes you know
Eric Bolling is from Fox News
yes son died yes he Bill O'Reilly does
an interview and he goes the media's got
to take some responsibility
and he says Eric Bolling son died and
it's the media's fault
and even Eric Bolling is like okay
listen the [ __ ] yeah that's that's
that's bizarre yeah where is Eric
Bolling now well he said don't drag my
dead son into your sexual harassment
scandal right now and it's a pretty cool
guy yeah Wow
don't drag my dick you never want to see
to have anything written after don't
drag my dead son into that's never good
for you as never but no matter how the
[ __ ] you mention is dead it has nothing
to do with anything
yeah that's [ __ ] up he apologized but
let's say he really yeah well Riley did
yeah he's really so just to get this
straight so Riley now where is he doing
this new these videos from the house is
a house okay I mean I've seen I saw it
like his studio quote-unquote it's like
in his little house office you could see
his books in the background as little
computer desk it's like any other it
looks cheaper than most youtubers but
he's kind of a prick seems like a prick
not for politics but as a guy he seems
like a prick right so people are kind of
happy to see him in trouble cuz you just
assume well I'll be honest with you
listen I dealt with the guy I did his
show a couple times got into arguments
with him you know about politics
whatever but you know he was he had a
good sense of humor on the air whatever
the product was TV show or a movie or a
book you know he was pushing it I ran
into him a couple times you know out at
charity events and you know I only dealt
with him in little doses and he seemed
fun but again that's the same thing you
can say about Harvey Weinstein right
here I only dealt with him on a certain
level you have no [ __ ] idea what's
going on behind the scene and you're not
the guy we're not the people that he's
gonna be at like I'm not the guy that's
gonna be asked to give a massage like
you I mean I'm not gonna see that side
of them ever so it's only like when you
don't see it yeah they seem fine like we
did Harvey once I don't know him that
was fine of course he was he was selling
the movies not gonna come in and go by
the way I've been putting my dick in
women's faces for 30 years yeah he's not
going to admit that and then trying to
see me shower Jim yeah what a crazy man
what a crazy follow up - no I won't
massage you
[ __ ] yeah well that's a great gift
Thanks
what [ __ ] a bright it's one of those
things readers when it first came out
you had to read the article like three
times because I like Travers never ever
be like no no I'm pretty sure it says he
would watch them showers right no that
makes sense
yeah no no watch me shower this says he
would have the actresses wouldn't that
[ __ ] look I mean that is who the [ __ ]
even his doctor doesn't want to see him
think his [ __ ] clothes no oh my god
no you can leave the shirt on I was a by
the way what he's he's dead he's dead in
the water he can't come back into the
you know show business so unless he's
gonna do unless he gets a podcast on The
O'Reilly Network
well okay by the way there's an idea
yeah okay if they had a [ __ ] talk
show those two guys Barrow audience
would follow them to that you know to me
or even like you know Bill O'Reilly in
the mornings Harvey Weinstein afternoon
yes listen and and listen let's get a
line of products loofahs [ __ ] you know
how Sasha well yeah massage oil shower
gel imagine the shower conversate like
the habits about showering that those do
priced like they would just click ah my
god man I get you [ __ ] awesome
parties hoping for a second chance
no of course not he's dead it is
happened to Bill O'Reilly like a guy who
is gleefully taken down so many people
yeah I just can't understand being in
the business of taking people down when
you're take down a bowl yes you know
like you buddy I'd say it becomes that
bulletproof thing plus you listen listen
the [ __ ] these guys are in a sick
territory and Jim should know cuz he's
been in some of that territory some
strange behavior so they they it nothing
happens for a long time by the way it's
like that thirty two million dollar
summit that was probably for him was
like okay now I'm really getting out of
control right that's like everybody
who's like when I was giving away when I
was settling for fifteen million yeah
thirty two oh my god [ __ ] I'm over the
30 mark yeah but the guys are getting it
with it I'm a dirty guy and everybody
knows I'm a dirty guy yes and I've had
sex with some fans and I've had sex with
pay people but I think I'm not harassing
women at work yes like these guys are
[ __ ] there's positions of power and I
think I like O'Reilly who does moralize
yes I'm not trying to [ __ ] their
producers it's a professional people you
idiot I know and you know what these
guys are doing Jim Norton a favor
because you are now beginning to look
like a saint which is you know you're a
beacon of moral sensibility I'm just
honor and I don't mean that
who are like in certain businesses have
less rights or should be harassed
I'm only saying that like I'm honest
about my approach to people's these guys
are going into the guys I'm your boss no
woman has ever gone out with me that
didn't know this guy's a [ __ ] I wrote
a book about getting jerked off exactly
out of school all year all of your
partner's are willing all of them is a
huge different yes it's a huge
difference yes they are they cross all
types of social barriers and gender
barriers you know of course so what but
yeah but yeah it's the it's you're an
honest man right you're an honest
strange strangely driven man but there's
no [ __ ] [ __ ] than what you're
doing it may be to say play with my
nipples and I'll put you in a movie like
that's a bat of that creepy and I know
that second part is way Crawford you got
that [ __ ] Weinstein tape that that
the audio tape if I'm trying to get that
girl to go oh please come on pleading a
horrible [ __ ] rap I'm yeah
it's just bizarre just get in there just
gonna run she's gonna go in the room
[ __ ] you I'm a famous guy go [ __ ]
yourself you know I mean that was that
we're desperate yeah desperate desperate
don't embarrass me please please I'm
uncomfortable don't let just don't let
this ruin our friendship you don't want
to lose me as a friend don't let this
ruin don't like what a [ __ ] scum
you're doing wrong you're ruining this
yeah and now I hear that there's a piece
coming out in the couple of days or
tomorrow about his brother Bob Bob do
what he did or was Bob just hitting on
one girl I'm not I don't know all I'd I
have no idea right but what I heard is
that there's a piece coming out Bob some
woman came out last week and said Bob
sexually harassed her so well you're
probably already addressed her I thought
unless there's more but this is one
who's like a producer whatever she won
that they said that the lawyers had to
get involved because he wouldn't stop
asking her out or something yeah that's
the one I'm talking about yeah yeah we
talked about her yeah oh yeah it might
be the only one I don't know no I think
there's more coming oh yeah he's not so
history defense is gonna be I hey I'm
not as bad as Harvey yeah and I wasn't
using the shower thing I had another
know what it was right that's the
mentality though I'm sure that he liked
Harvey is so far off the spectrum that
like watching his brother do what he
does he could do unthink
things and it's still not gonna look as
bad right and yes probably and that's
probably how you justified it to himself
like I'm not I mean what I say you know
anybody with an addiction and whatever
messy thing it is you're part of the
part of the coming to the bottom of the
barrel is is pointing at other people
going like it but I'm not as bad as him
and I'm not as better Sam that's a great
defense right yeah I never I never
forced an actress yes exactly
when you're when you run a movie company
I Hey look there's all these beautiful
people your disposal but it's just it's
[ __ ] creepy to say to somebody I'll
get hurt your career if you don't do yes
yeah I actually think like he said to me
I mean that the [ __ ] that he was doing
with women was a completely different
sick twisted thing but he's the kind of
guy who was saying if the guys to it
I'll [ __ ] ruin your career you better
do this movie and I'll give you another
move like he's one of those [ __ ] guys
he just got in the business literally to
have that [ __ ] power and I can reel
me in being in the scenario that you
just described if you were just some
young actor right who just was desperate
for a role that wasn't kind of in
control of your own destiny that would
have been you know I would not be able
to answer that question because I would
I would hope but you know when you're
starving to death right you know I had
just made it right now I was like the
first movie I did I got paid scale like
$45,000 was the most money I'd ever made
in my life at one time you know that's
like I mean even working as a comic I
wasn't making that you know so yeah
that's a that's a you know there's
people ahead too you know probably had
to listen to his [ __ ] because they
wanted the [ __ ] chance to be in a
movie
well not if he had come to you a year
earlier yes before I made exactly my
image spots right you yeah like of
course the afraid I probably I probably
would have said yes and whatever the
[ __ ] thing was yeah I'm not I wasn't
gonna watch him take a shower I mean I
would think I'm not certain I wouldn't
touch him yeah a shower i justified in
my head well it's just a shower yeah
call Florence he after all make fun of
him but nobody sexually assaulted you on
the on the set of the Sandlot no oh
thank god I love that movie a weird
experience with a guy in Hollywood or no
Colin Quinn I just had like he would
walk around naked in my apartment after
he slept over and I was like dude put on
some [ __ ] underwear or something or a
towel so only
exactly most of my sexual harassment was
done by Colin quit yeah you know biting
his finger showing the colleague you
feel fun no idea no idea you wouldn't
wear pants why I don't know why you know
we'd come home he would stay at my house
if he came to Boston to work and you
know as soon as we got back to the
apartment he just [ __ ] take his
t-shirt in his pants of it being his
underwear like dude my girlfriend lives
here too he's at work
like put some [ __ ] pants on I mean
Colin but you know he's not the guy that
like he's a guy who benefits from
clothes yes even when we were young he
benefited from [ __ ] clothes but I'll
tell you something that Colin Quinn
invented that I you know I have to give
him full credit for and that was the the
[ __ ] out
you know [ __ ] on NBA players face thing
you guys know about that it was the
greatest [ __ ] thing ever so I can't
remember exactly what year it was but it
was during the 80s heyday when the
Lakers and the Celtics were you know at
each other's throat in the finals like
every year and he was he would be in
Boston at my apartment or sometimes here
in New York and he'd be rootin for the
Celtics versus the Lakers but like the
Celtics I have to get by the Pistons you
know what usually to get to them to the
finals and we hated Bill Laimbeer
as self-experience and colleges stood
Glen beard fouled bird took him down and
Colin just stood up we're all yelling at
the TV and he just stood up and unzip
took his [ __ ] out and he said I'm just
gonna put it on film in bear's face and
every time they did a close of a lamb
beer he put his [ __ ] in his face and
that became this thing that we all did
whenever they were playing and it's just
carrying on for years like every time I
see blue colombians face I think a colin
coins [ __ ] and it's just it'll go like
that forever until I die it's awesome I
started dude we all started taking it
out and putting on people's faces when
you're watching the game I was much more
[ __ ] up put it on the face of Vinnie
of the microwave Johnson that that's who
named Micah Micah Johnson yeah yeah put
your dick on his face oh I hated that
piston team so much you know they were
[ __ ] Isiah Thomas Isiah Thomas Rodman
young Rodman they know eventually were a
great team but I [ __ ] hated him Robin
played yeah he started out with the
pitch yeah as a matter of fact one of
the famous moments in Celtic history was
when the Pistons thought they had game
six won against the Celtics when
Larry Bird stole the pass Isaiah Thomas
is with like two seconds on the clock
and passed the DJ Dennis Johnson and he
put it in but for that right before that
play happened Robin was already
celebrating running around with this you
know fingers in the air like we're
number one and then bird won Game six
and then we beat him in Game seven and
at the end of Game seven Burt walked
around with yeah and you know Colin
Quinn's [ __ ] was on are you actually a
doctor my wife are you a doctor
I am one of those celebrities my alma
mater yeah and I went to Emerson College
in Boston and I actually was a good
student I started acting and writing I
loved college it was great and then
because I got famous they asked me to
come you know they do that with famous
people you come and go you got a doctor
you give the great graduations sure yeah
yeah and and they give you an actual
doctorate framed
and you're officially a doctor I want to
give Syracuse I would I would like to
but my at the high school thing yeah you
don't have to get the I know I'm a
plumber from high school no famous and
and they ask you you get the degree when
that be great if Jim did a speech at a
high school graduation yeah it actually
would be awesome yeah you can do it yeah
yeah high school just ask you when I
come in and speak really and they're
like yeah maybe you could miss me I'm
like okay and then they guy what are you
gonna talk about I'm like what you
[ __ ] asked me to send you topic list
you know what I wasn't you pick me up
what did you say I didn't write it back
that's fine I'm a begging my way near so
I'm not trying to use this as a credit
if you want me to you need a
pre-interview going into the high school
graduations be talk about how
unimportant this is yeah school yeah
luckily I did get out get out now get
out fit yeah will you nervous given that
speech no you aren't I'll tell you why
because I graduated from college and I
remember I Michael Dukakis remember
Michael discussion he spoke at my
graduation and it [ __ ] went on for
ever it must have been an hour and
fifteen minutes and you remember that
guy was one of the most boring human he
was right off and he droned on and on
all we wanted to do we got the degrees
you know we wanted to go to the [ __ ]
party yeah so my speech was
literally about 12 seconds long and all
I did was get up there and go ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank the people are
members of college from making me a
doctor
let's go [ __ ] party and that way and
they knew I was done and they went crazy
I got a standing ovation that's it yeah
that's what seconds of work and they
went to the party and we had a great
time you know so if you get if they ask
you to be a doctor don't make something
stupid important speech right just let
the kids go to the party go ahead go
talk to him have fun be flanking because
every graduation is the same set up
right the opening for a graduation is
the kids actually get the thing sir and
then all the [ __ ] do these [ __ ]
self-important speeches
yeah we had Billy Joel at our graduation
you really knew he was actually pretty
good he started singing a song oh no you
say he made up some song about Syracuse
nice singing it was like five minutes it
was a good life he did some yard work
for me with the tree my yard before the
jane goodall which was kind of okay with
missing jane goodall is the one who's
the lady
yeah no I'm not gonna just had the I and
Fosse was the other one the Sigourney
Weaver played who's dead
I believe it name is Dian Fossey the
other ape lady and and they were both
played by Sigourney Weaver Noster going
to play duh did she play good I don't
know I thought she played Dian Fossey I
don't know yeah oh no you guys have guys
who can google this right now Sigourney
with sa Geor how about just Dian Fossey
Dian Fossey
he's never no way he's getting Fosse
there is no way he's getting fossee it's
not gonna happen
dying it for my clothes I she's she no
she was kidding she was killed
yeah she was killed murdered by poachers
or some [ __ ] she died in 85 I think I
don't remember that's a really sad any
that movie yes